this has been a catalyst year for
women's sports with record-breaking
numbers around the world
the appetite has never been bigger but
they're still playing for a fraction of
what men get paid
now let's take a look at why that is and
how it can possibly change
tennis has been light years ahead of
other sports in terms of equal pay with
every major offering equal prize money
for men and women since 2007 a fight
pioneered by billie jean king in 1973
when she successfully threatened to
boycott the us open so why has tennis
been able to achieve something no other
global sport has yet to figure out
well the major tournaments for men and
women are played in the same place at
the same time so it was easy to
cultivate the same fan for both sides
in fact in some cases the women outdrew
the men according to nielsen at the 2021
u.s open the women's match was watched
by nearly 2.5 million viewers and the
men's drew just under 2.1 million so are
the two related equal pay and audience
popularity the simple answer is yes but
things are much more complicated than
that
soccer has seen perhaps the biggest
equal pay fight in sports since billie
jean king
after a three-year battle the u.s
women's national team finally came to an
agreement with u.s soccer this may on a
deal that would give them equal pay as
the men for the same appearances
the fight was long but justifiable and
not just because of their on-the-field
dominance being four-time world cup
champions and having four olympic gold
medals
this team is popular and people tune in
to watch them play
they own the record for most watched
soccer game in u.s history for the 2015
world cup final which 25.4 million
people tuned into
and in 2021 a down year from any major
tournaments they averaged 435 000
viewers per game
on par with the men who averaged 599 000
on a year where they were looking to
secure their first world cup birth since
2014. with this new deal the us joins
five other countries as national teams
that have promised equal pay for their
men's and women's soccer teams
a feat that seems years away when
looking at league play
the payout is incredibly different and
there is a massive drop-off in
viewership
according to nielsen in 2021 the mls cup
was watched by nearly 1.2 million people
while the nwsl final was about half of
that at 535 000 viewers
so why the drop-off
well when you take a look at broadcast
deals they don't even compare
the mls currently has a tv deal worth
more than 90 million dollars a year to
play on espn fox and univision
and the nwsl just signed a deal worth
2.5 million a year for their games to be
shown on streaming services such as
paramount plus and twitch
accessibility could be the key here to
the gap in viewership
playing on major networks versus playing
on streaming services that not everybody
has access to could hinder fans from
watching
it's hard to be a fan of a game you
can't watch
so a way to get more consistent
viewership is by giving fans access to
the games but that may take a leap of
faith from broadcasters but it's proven
for the national team so it isn't
impossible
[Music]
you